Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 12th, 2016 what's going on? How are you, uh,
I've gotta be a little quiet man. It's only like six 30 in the morning out here,
but my lovely wife is still sleeping and uh,
so I'm trying not to wake her up. Um, upstairs can try to be a good boy,
these folk and weaker, right? I'm still gonna say all the fucked up shit.
I always say, I'm just going to say it at a volume that's, you know,
a little more palatable thought down, throttled slapping. You know,
I woke up this morning by [inaudible] I heard this big fucking booming noise and
uh, you ever get that feeling like you're like,
did I just dream that or somebody in the house, right?
And then you immediately start thinking like, all right, I got kitchen knives.
I got a fucking softball bat right next to my bed. And, uh,
but the reality is, you know,
as much as people are want gun control and all of that shit,
I mean that's the first thing you think of. You know, the radio,
you know, this should be a fucking thing, right? Where if you can, if you,
if they can fucking test you one God damn time,
so like five fucking questions,
then all of a sudden you never have to go through any sort of fucking, you know,
major security at the airport because one time you didn't act like a fucking
lunatic and then I guess you're good for the rest of your life.
Why can't just like one time they can't come up with the same type of a test,
whatever the fuck they see down at the airport.
They can't come up with that for fucking regular people, you know,
you know,
be perfect just to have a fucking 38 and they let you have a silencer now.
Fuck that. A Glock with the silencer cause you don't want to ruin your ears.
You just want to kill the person that comes in your house. Right. It'd be great.
Be Right there next to your table and the person comes walking in,
you know faggy man, are you fucking money? Just reach over to,
to the fucking hit the ground. You put the gun back down.
You just go back to sleep and you know, a couple of hours way back up again.
You like it was, I say your brother lock him up. Oh. Oh,
that's right. That's right. Ali. Yeah. While you were sleeping,
some guy broken. Yeah. [inaudible] um,
you want to Wa you want to call the cops? I'll get some a, you know,
get the coffee going. You know,
everybody, you know, they tell you don't have a knife or anything like that.
You want back, we'll give you distance. But at the end of the day,
you know what I mean? There has to be some sort of test.
They look at you fucking driving record, right? How you did in high school.
Jesus. I'd be out the window. I don't know what the fuck.
However the fuck they do it. Okay. And you know, you just get, you get,
you get a glock with the fucking silencer. You don't hurt your ears, you know,
aim center mass or whatever be, it would be a great fucking thing.
I really think it would be a great thing. You know,
as long as you knew what everybody's feet sounded like on the floor in your
house, as long as you knew what you knew, what their walks sounded like,
that would be the test right there. All your loved ones in your house,
they would from bare feet to fucking snow shoes.
You just had to be like all, that's my son Mikey.
Okay. That's my wife and she's wearing uggs. Right. And you get it all down.
All right, so then you know what the fucking sound is.
I don't know. I'm just saying I had a little fucking iron annoys.
I get a little nervous and I was just like,
what am I Jason Fucking born over here? I'm not, you know,
my wife's been snoring to beat the fucking band now that she's in the third
trimester, which is understandable. The kids laying on her fucking lungs. So A,
I have to go upstairs to sleep and I,
I had all of this shit went through my fucking head. All right.
Like what if somebody came and downstairs took out my wife and left with no
fucking fingerprints? They're gonna fucking blame me.
That's the first thing I thought. Not, oh my God,
my pregnant wife was going to be dead.
First thing I thought is I'm going to go to jail for that shit. That's what,
you know, I'm really selfish when I'm in the middle of the night,
I'm really groggy. Like, like right now I'm awake. And I'd be like, well, I,
I would be too. I wouldn't give a fuck what they did to me at that point.
I'd be so upset that I lost my wife.
But when I'm laying here nice and toasty under the sheets,
that's the first thing I thought of. Like, Oh man, I love this bed. That man,
I wouldn't have this bed and jail
anyways. Um, we're getting down to a people.
There's only another fucking, uh, 19 days left in
this year to fuck Christmas, by the way.
Fuck Christmas right up the old fucking Yahoo. All right.
Fuck that stupid ass fucking holidays for fucking kids.
The level of fucking pressure I have to run around and buy fucking adults
fucking presence. What do you want to shoot? You train. You fucking can't.
I don't have time for this shit. I got too much other stuff to do it.
They needed that that day. Yeah.
Okay.
It's fucking brutal, man. I had one of the worst, one of the worst. Fuck.
I wasn't going to talk about this.
I had one of the worst fucking weeks of my life and this Christmas music in the
background is fucking driving me nuts.
I'm going to gloss over all of this shit because, um,
I've never gotten emotional on the podcast. I do not want to do it now. Uh,
you know,
I told you one of my good friends died and went to the memorial service and you
know is too, you know, he's got two kids, 10 years old,
went up and spoke at it was the most heart wrenching thing I ever saw.
And then Thursday,
I know this is going to be probably devastating to a lot of you guys.
I had to give my dog away. Yes. Oh,
cleo. I had to do it.
I got a baby coming and I'm the Cleo that you hear on the podcast is not the
Cleo that I'm
unfortunately when anybody else comes to the door. And uh, you know,
she tried to attack my parents, my brother in law, my father in law,
all of my friends, she bit,
one of my friends nipped him and was just like, uh, it,
you know,
it was a ticking fucking time bond for seven years with the dog.
I love the dog to death. My wife loves the dog.
It was fucking devastated. It's the most devastating thing I've had to do.
It's just one of those adult decisions where it was like my brain was like,
there's no fucking way you can have a baby crawling around that then becomes a
toddler and they don't know how to fucking pet a dog.
And then she gets a little older and then has friends over and their parents
come over. It was just a, it was a ticking time bomb.
She does not do well adjusting to new things and something horrible was going to
happen and then she was going to get put down so I had to do the responsible
thing and a founder a great home.
And this is what kills me is she's totally adjusted now and it's fucking
happiest shit and I'm fucking devastated cause she's a fucking dog and within
four days, so like, oh is this the new deal? You're the guy now. Alright.
Um, so um,
okay
I'll tell you a quick story dude.
Fucking I had the hand the dog off to my trainer, right?
So the whole morning I don't want to act emotional cause I don't want the dog to
be nervous and uh, so I took her on one last hike,
it was fucking brutal and I'm,
then I was gathering up all his stuff.
I give it all to the trainer and I go to hand off the fucking dog and it's like
I didn't want her to be nervous so I barely even said goodbye.
I was like all right buddy. Okay. See you later.
Cause I didn't want it to be nervous cause I love it so much.
And then I fucking, you know,
you know the trainer takes it and then I went back in the house,
went in the bathroom and then fucking cried like a little boy.
It was fucking brutal. Brutal. You know,
it's fucking hilarious the way women handle this fucking emotion,
like my wife like sobbed like five or six fucking times,
including the night before. And then they,
their ability to fucking move ahead is,
is fucking astounding. Like they can, they can,
no, it's sad deal with it being sad.
They fucking cry it out of them.
And then I'm not saying she's not heartbroken, she's fucking devastated.
But like their ability,
their fucking ability to handle shit like that versus a guy guys fucking denied,
denied, denied and then they hold onto the shit. You know what I mean?
Everybody's got that fucking buddy of theirs, you know what I mean?
They're married, they got a couple of kids, but you get like two,
three scotches in 'em. They talk,
start talking about some broad from fucking 25 years ago. It's like, dude,
when are you going to let it go? Cause you know, we were not allowed.
Like when I cried over my dog the whole time I was fighting itself,
it was like an eight second cry. [inaudible] done. All right.
Fight it off her. Just keep it right there in your chest.
Keep it fucking right there. And then, you know,
I'm telling you fucking like nine years from now,
be at a fucking Christmas party and have a couple too,
too many fucking zinfandels. And I'll lash out at somebody and they'd be like,
dude, where the fuck did that come from? And it's,
and I'm not even going to know it's going to be because I didn't hug my dog
before. I mean, I definitely, you know,
I did with the days coming up and that type of shit,
but I should've given it one last fucking hug, but I knew I couldn't do it,
you know? Um, so all right, let's pass that.
Let's get past that anyways.
Okay.
So I went to the rams game yesterday. Uh, by the way,
I did hit pause to regroup. Brutal,
brutal fucking [inaudible].
And the whole fucking time I got to sit and listen to fucking Christmas music
everywhere I go in Florida. You know,
if I had a hammer, I'd hammer. Is that a fucking Christmas song?
It's kind of a fucking psycho song, right? Second adults is, if I had a hammer,
we all know what a hammer is for two. All right? I don't know.
I always get nervous when I hear that first sentence, if I had a hammer. Um,
anyways, so I went to the rams for, um,
the Atlanta Falcons game yesterday.
A buddy of mine had tickets and uh, I was like, dude, I gotta go.
Cause I really wanted to see the Los Angeles Rams playing in the La Memorial
Coliseum. I mean, that's where all the greats played from the rams history.
Right. I believe Eric Dickerson played there before he went to, uh,
before they moved down to Anaheim.
Probably the last of the greatest to play there. Uh,
the fearsome foursome, right? Lamar, Lamar, Lundy,
Merlin Olsen, Rosie Greer, Deacon Jones.
Whether that was Roman Gabriel, that was all before my time.
Then I came in when it was the fucking quarterback controversy of Pat Hayden,
Vince Ferragamo, Wendell Tyler,
right? Jim and Jack Young blood. What was crazy about them as back then,
if somebody had the same always, if somebody has the same last name as you,
they put just your first initial and then a period. But it was Jack and Jim.
So they had to write their whole names and said Jack Young blood on the back.
It never looked right. It looked fucking weird. Um,
but anyways, um, I went there and, uh, it was the typical,
uh, sporting experience that you,
a lot of times where there's just as many fans, if not more fans,
because it's a transience city. It really has nothing to do with La fans.
There's just so many people like myself that moved out here, you know,
chasing the old Hollywood dream. Or if people are just fucking sick of, um,
you know, just bad weather. People are just always fucking moving it,
by the way, dude, I'm telling you right now, dude,
this fucking real estate bubble out here of them building all of these fucking
luxury apartment buildings.
You know where I fucking go over and play hockey the,
they got this thing of the Pickwick,
a hockey thing that's also a bowling alley and a function room.
They fucking knock in that whole thing down,
knocking that whole fucking thing down. Cause they're gonna
have luxury apartments.
It's just there's going to be no place to skate out here.
The one that was over in fucking, was it century city or some shit?
Get confused over there. Begins with a c and ain't cut. I don't know what it is.
They fucking, that one's done. Now this one's gone. The only one. That one's,
I know there's one down by the airport and there's one over near him,
like a near Sherman Oaks Valley Ice Center.
And other than that, uh, I don't know.
I left the fucking go buy some roller blades, right?
Some little fucking short shorts do that stupid thing. You know,
we set up the cones and you'd come up to them and turn around backwards, right?
Um, anyways, uh, yeah dude.
So they have a, so they had this distinct put up, this fucking one building,
right. And a really impressive building. It's over near Beverly Hills.
So I was just like, Hey, you know, let's see what that build is about.
I go on the Internet, right? It's called the 10,000. I'm like, all right,
why is it called the 10 dot?
It's called the 10,000 because that's the amount of money,
money you have to pay a month to live there because bare minimum,
how fucking Takis? Like how many times are we going to fucking do this?
You know what I mean? It's like we always act.
There's always like some sort of like trash and everybody fucking loses
everything. And by everybody,
I mean the fucking lower 99% gets their fucking asses kicked and then,
you know, give it a couple of years.
Then all of a sudden it just comes right back out around again to the bud.
Fox greed is good dude. How fucking tacky is that?
The name of the building is the minimal.
This is how much you're paying and rent.
Jesus Christ have a little bit of fucking class. Um,
yeah, they're just everywhere. They're putting up luxury apartments.
I don't know where the fuck they going to find all these people to, to,
to fill these things, but I guarantee you, um, they're not going to do it.
Like I was thinking of buying a small apartment building out here,
but everybody's fucking buying them up.
I can't even afford to fucking get in one or you know, just cause it's stupid.
It's like at the height, the fucking market, you know,
I was thinking of buying like a parking garage or some shit. Just a parking lot,
you know? Fuck. Are All these people going to park? You said building,
parking underneath the goddamn things. Yeah, they got it all figured out.
You know, I guess I'll be telling jokes for the rest of my fucking life.
I'm trying to have some sort of something,
a lemonade stand or something where I get into my older fucking years.
I got some sort of loot coming in that doesn't have to do with me fucking
putting on my tap dancing shoes. I don't know. So anyways, I went to the, um,
the, uh,
Los Angeles Rams game yesterday and it was so great to see them play there even
though they had a fucking brutal game.
They were down 42 to nothing to Maddie ice and fucking, uh,
uh, fucking the rams and I, I mean the,
the Falcons and evidently their best receiver, whoever the fuck that is,
Julio Jones is some shit. I think I heard that name.
I is that a baseball player? I Dunno.
I don't play fantasy sports and I'm too fucking busy to really pay attention as
much as I used to.
He wasn't even playing and they just kicked the shit out of him. You know,
it was funny. The rams finally scored a touchdown, right to make it 42 to seven,
and they lit the Olympic torch.
I'm sure they just light it late at night,
but it seemed like that's when I first noticed that it was on.
And then they also had a, a, a fumble recovery for a touchdown.
The crowd's going nuts. So whenever that happens live,
the first thing I do is try to pick up a referee to see if I see,
you know him going, no, no, no, no, no. It's a dead ball.
Or if he say and touchdown. And as the guy was crossing the Golan,
you could see the ref was already going. No, no, no.
Pointing at the ground saying was, you know,
neither the guy was down or whatever. Right. And the fucking fireworks guy,
the fucking fireworks guy shoots the fireworks off on a touchdown that got
called back. It's fucking hilarious because they're not selling out games.
You know, that probably got, I bet that guy got chewed out.
Fucking owner probably came down his camel hair coat. You know,
where the fuck is a God damn fireworks guy. I'm sorry,
Mr Mr fucking owner. I have to shut the fuck up, right?
It's coming out of your pay. It's down there fucking crying. Um,
but it was just such a great stadium. It holds 90,000 people for the life of me.
Can somebody explain to me
why the Los Angeles Rams need a new football stadium?
There's a football stadium, there's two of them.
There's the rose bowl and there's the fucking La Memorial Coliseum.
Why do we have to take more fucking natural resources out of the fucking earth
to build another one of these stupid ass fucking stadiums? How's it?
They get to have luxury boxes and put all the bells and whistles on it,
you know,
so they can attract people who aren't into sports to go to the fucking event.
I love that fucking stadium. I had a great time. I love that.
It's a so called shit hole. I think it's great.
Do you know there was 62 steps to get from fucking where I was seating sitting
back up to the main concourse to fucking walk out of the stadium.
It's fucking tremendous. 62 steps, you know,
it makes you drink less. You're burning a bunch of calories,
there's less fat fucks, but now what do they say? Oh, that's a fire hazard.
Okay.
The inclines to steep and we'll get with fucking was so soft in this fucking
country.
That's why like everybody's trying to get me all freaked out about having a kid
about how difficult it's going to be.
And I'm not saying it's not going to be difficult, but it's like people,
women used to have kids and then they'd fucking die.
And then the fucking guy had to go out,
bury his wife and get behind a team of oxen,
plow some rocky God damn field and then fucking, I don't know, feed the kid,
I don't know goats milk at that point. I have no idea. And somehow we did it.
You know,
people who have survived plagues,
I can't fucking be in a house with central air conditioning and heat and all of
this shit. I, I, you know, I mean, how much fucking harder is,
Oh God,
I wish parents from fucking in the past could come and listen to [inaudible] the
way people fucking whine and go on and on about themselves,
you know, and the way they lecture people who don't have kids do, do, hey,
you have no idea. Oh my God, it's so, shut the fuck up.
These fucking people coming over, you know,
come paddle it over from Cuba on a fucking refrigerator door,
fighting off sharks. You know, you can't hit,
you can't change a couple of diapers. I'm telling you,
people are fucking dead pussies. They're fucking soft. People are fucking soft.
They fucking bitch, Moan and complain. Yes, yes. There's things in life,
you know, I say at this point with all the modern gadgets,
all right, if you have a job,
if you're not worried about money as far as you have enough fucking money to
make your rent and all that stuff, I mean,
a kid shouldn't be any more difficult considering the love back that you're
going to get other than, you know,
a major fucking adjustment and something that's inconvenient. But I mean,
come on. It's difficult. Yeah. Compared to the rest of the, compared to what?
Sitting down and playing police station at fucking 38 years of age. Uh,
I might eat these words, but I mean, I'm just comparing it to the fact that,
you know, it's, people used to live in the fucking middle of nowhere.
They'd have like 14 fucking kids.
I can't handle one. I got all the sports packages, right. I mean, what, I mean,
my fucking life's a joke. Literally.
Um,
anyways, I, I don't know. Well, let's, let's try to stay on top of it.
I have no fucking idea. Um, why they need a new stadium.
It's, it's, uh, you know, I can't talk and type in my,
I'm on
stick with the bill focus. Oh. And he does it. Um, anyway,
so we went to the game and uh, I had a great time and uh,
the fucking Atlanta fans will like chit the amount of shit-talking.
Dude, there was this one guy, this one fucking guy,
he bought those fucking wide receiver gloves, you know,
where they have the logo with the team and then they cross the hands and they
put their hands up over their heads. You know,
like when like the fucking franchise player scores a touchdown.
He does that and it looks cool. He was doing that at the end of the game,
just holding his hands up, facing facing the fucking,
um, rams fed. I'm telling you, dude, this guy was like 50.
All right. You know, all wired thin,
you know street dude, right? 50 years old.
And he walked out and he was making, doing a selfie video as he walked out,
you know, talk it, all this shit. It's like, dude, you beat the fucking ramps.
I mean, what's fucking relaxed?
You're not beating the giants in at beaten Seattle.
You're not beating the cowboys. You not doing shit this year.
Fucking guy running out like they just want to play a game.
I don't know what it is about me,
but I fucking hate when the fans from the visiting team take over a stadium.
Even if I don't give a fuck about the team, I respect the ram.
So next thing you know, I'm talking all this shit to rams fan.
I mean to falcons fans in the back of my head. I'm like,
why are you doing this bill? You don't give a fuck. It's just a rams fans.
They didn't have any big, they weren't coming with the shit. Talk back.
They couldn't. They were down 42 seven, right?
42 14 I think was the final. So at one point,
you know when they went up 42 to nothing,
all these falcon fancy start Chiton a t l a t.
L. A. T. L. N. I just started yelling,
you're a hub city. No one goes to Atlanta.
We pass through your city onto our final destination.
Started yelling all this shit about Delta Airlines.
I believe that that's the hub there. Um,
and afterwards I just started thinking, why do I care? Oh.
And then I also screamed at the fucking Atlanta's punter.
He fucking punted the ball and this guy had a nice run back and then he'd get,
comes off the field. Now granted,
he could have been mad that he kicked it to the wrong guy or you supposed to
kick it away.
But he came off the field and he did the double fucking pulling the Chin straps
off. And he was like, fuck screaming all this shit.
He was all upset. I fuck it went off on him.
I don't even remember what the fuck I said.
I was just so beside myself that a punter would talk that level of shit.
Like just sit the fuck down. Have,
they washed your uniform once this year, fucking dope.
You're closer to sit in the stands than you are actually being on that fucking
do you know what I mean? You don't, it'd be like,
it'd be like if this guy was in the army and he's,
he like peels potatoes and he's talking shit cause he cut his finger or
something like that.
And meanwhile he's sitting around a bunch of people that just came back from the
front lines. That's how I look at it. I mean, I might be a content,
I have no idea. So anyways, when I was sitting there watching the rams game, um,
I mentioned to my buddy that, uh, how there used to be a, uh,
a football stadium. I couldn't remember the name of it.
I first I said the baker bowl and I was like, I think that might be in Philly.
Um, but there was a, there was a stadium for anybody who lives out here in la.
A lot of people, you know, La is really bad about their history.
And um, they had a stadium, uh,
that was down where the farmer's market is. And on Fairfax.
And Beverly was actually a baseball stadium there too.
I don't know anything about that.
But they had a stadium called the Gilmore Stadium and called Gilmore Stadium and
they had a couple of NFL, like all star Games there.
And then they had like some defunct football league,
like the La bulldogs or some shit played there. I looked,
looked it up on Wikipedia, um, early this morning and I couldn't, uh,
couldn't sleep that well. A little heartbroken.
Billy here couldn't sleep last night. And um,
then the baseball field that was next to it, if you ever watched those classic,
um,
home run derbies well they have like Al Kayline versus like Mickey Mantle and
Shit and you know, they're in La and you're like,
where the fuck is that stadium? Um,
they filmed a lot of it at the stadium right next to it.
And right now there's like the cvs lot there where they film like the prices
right and shit. And as I was looking that up, I didn't know this.
They actually had a Wrigley field in La that looks like a, from the map,
it was near or north of Watts, la,
which is south of the 10 and east of the one 10.
And it was built by the same guy that made Wrigley Field in Chicago and Comiskey
field. I'm a fucking nerd. I like looking up that shit.
I looked up shit about the rams. They've won one Superbowl,
they won it in St Louis, obviously 1999 people will remember that.
And they want an NFL title in 1945 when they were still in Cleveland,
which is where they started. So, um,
they've never won an NFL title or a fucking Superbowl here in la.
And I gotta tell you after watching them yesterday,
they don't seem like they're that much closer.
Fucking Jeff Fisher taken all kinds of shit,
all kinds of shit. Um, they need to fire them.
They need to fire his ass. All right, well who do you think,
who else is we going to replace them with? You got to have a replacement.
I mean, this guy's been in the fucking league forever.
Did take a team to the Superbowl. However, it was fucking 17 years ago.
He did well with Vince Young, you know, but in defense of him,
you know, if you look at the last,
since the Patriots started going to the Superbowl, okay,
the Patriots have gone to six fucking Superbowls. Alright.
And then as far as winning patriots have won,
four Steelers won two giants. One, two
packers. One. Why me? It's like literally like every fucking decade.
There's like two or three teams that just fucking run the table and the fucking
nineties. It was a cowboys won three Broncos. One, two.
There's half the Superbowl's a fucking gone right there.
And you knew the 49 is we're going to get one and they want for the previous
decade. There's just always that Steelers one for in.
Um, let's look at the 80s. The eighties. It was uh,
49 is one for the Raiders one too.
That's six gone right there. Giants. One one.
Yeah.
Redskins won one Redskins. One, two. All right,
so that's four, two and two. You got three teams that want eight of the 10,
and then it was the bears and whatever the fuck else I just said.
I can't remember. Um, one, the other one, uh,
wait a minute. Where does it go? It goes
Raiders 40 niners
Redskins Raiders 40 niners bears,
giants Redskins 49 is 49. Oh,
giants is the other one's giants and bears one one. Alright, I'm sorry,
I'm getting all fucking nerded out here with the, uh,
with the fucking sports talk here. Um,
which I'll probably do a little bit more of, but, um,
I probably should do some advertising here, but I want to talk to you guys, uh,
about some shit where, um, I told you I've been starting to get, uh,
my fond someone, you know,
I fucked up my backlash this year with the psychotic nerd thing. Hey,
right. I went through all of that shit through that.
I found a great crack chiropractor and then a great misuse,
which has led me to this other person that I just went to ooze. Um,
you know, a former like Mr Universe, bodybuilder and all that,
and he's a fucking genius. And everything in a,
I went to go see this guy because a, I fucked up my rotator cuff like years ago,
I've been trying to just fight through it and all that type of shit.
And I finally went to go see this guy and like I came walking in and you know
those body builders, they spend their lives just looking in the mirror,
you know, with fucking clothes on. He just saw all of my shit. It was it.
He just went like, I, you shoulders are rotated forward. You left.
One is actually closer to your neck than your right one is.
And then he goes and he goes, stand in the mirror. You see that?
Did I brush my teeth every fucking twice a day, right? Two,
three times a fucking day. I've never noticed that Mike. Holy Shit, he's right.
Cause it's rotated in and turned ever so slightly.
It's not like it's like fucking three inches, but you really have to look at it.
And then he goes, all right, do me a favor,
turn your head to the left and turn it to the right.
And then he just started smiling because he knew what my fucking issue was. Um,
whatever you,
that neck muscle is Mike chest and my trap muscles are too fucking tight and you
trap easy muscle, whatever it is,
it goes all the way down to the middle of your back.
But mine is super tight up top and my chest is tight.
So it's pulling everything forward and it's making my shoulders go up.
Like my shoulders always go up like, so he gave me this fucking stretch.
Um, even if you don't have this fucking problem, I got to tell,
hopefully I can describe it over the podcast here is just stand up straight,
right? And then just lift your chest up,
put your shoulders back, put your fucking shoulders back, lift your chest up,
like to like you feel like you're trying to make it.
Go to the ceiling and then have your hands, your arms.
Bring your arms back behind you, palms up and stretch back as far as you can.
All right.
Like you're totally opening up your chest as you bring your arms back and try to
hold that for a minute. Um,
it's been a complete game changing now.
So like my shoulders have come down cause I didn't want to my Seuss,
she beat the fuck out of my neck and uh,
my shoulders a fucking down a little bit more.
But like I swear to God what I used to do, like, um, yoga stretches,
like on one side I could totally like, you know, they always bag,
reach around and grab your arm or whatever that Yoga Shit,
I could totally do it on one side, could not do it on the other side.
And I'm for my whole life, like I've had this fucking problem,
like one shoulder being higher than the other forever. You know,
when some nurse when I was in high school goes, Oh,
you got a little bit of scoliosis. Yeah, your spine is a little curved and blah,
blah blah blah blah. And like, and this fucking who's,
I don't know the fuck she was. I was just like, yeah, that's the problem.
And it wasn't. So I talked to this guy who was just going like, oh yeah,
he goes, I'll have you fucking straightened out in like a month or something.
And uh,
so he gave me these exercises to strengthen up the lower part of the trapezius
or whatever. And for the first time in my life,
I'm going to actually be able to sit up straight just naturally. And um,
it, the amount of shit that it is affected,
it's given me back problems like playing drums and stuff like I forever,
and having to like a just shit and wondering why when like I sit down,
like why I have to bring the snare higher than I should have to bring it,
you know? And everybody else would just sit down and be, no,
it seems pretty normal to me.
I had no fucking idea what the deal was and evidently I was all crooked, up top.
So, um,
I gotta tell you that's something that I've learned this year when the biggest
things I've learned this year,
um,
is like how medicine,
if you go to a shoulder doctor, he's just gonna fucking look at your shoulder.
You know what I mean? You got to get back dark.
He's just looking at your fucking back. But you go to these,
these messsage and people like that,
they how the whole fucking body works and they understand like, oh,
this is pulled out of alignment.
It always comes down to balance where it's like these muscles are too tight and
the eye muscles on the other side a two weeks.
So this is either pulling this forward or pulling this back,
which is causing you to compensate when you walk. And that's like,
you literally have a problem with you,
your left foot because of your right shoulder.
It's fucking amazing if you get a good one. All right.
You go to some rugged Robin tug place. She's still gonna have a crooked back,
but oh, you're going to walk out with a smile on your face. Sorry.
Um, all right. I know. I haven't been this too funny. All right,
I'm going through a lot of shit here. All right, let me, let me read the, um,
let me read the, uh, the advertising here for this week. Okay. Oh Jesus.
Here we go. Dollar Shave Club. Everybody. Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing,
affordable raises right to your door every month.
So you can get a great shave,
but raises aren't the only thing you need in the bathroom.
What about all the shower stuff? Turns out dollar Shave Club.
Thought of that too. You know what the reality is? All you need is shampoo,
shampoo, still soap. If you want to show itself a shampoo,
all these different types of fucking, you know, why did you try,
did you pay it back in the day? You sat in a fucking tub? You know,
they, they didn't have any soap that they, and like kill a fucking,
go to some shit. I don't know.
I don't know how to turn the grease and just a bar of soap.
How often would you do? I don't fucking know. You jumped in a river, a,
they just came out with a new line of shower products, shampoo and body wash,
shampoo and body wash called the wanderer.
I love this champion body wash in one. Perfect.
The fragrances are unlike anything on the market.
They're subtle and actually smell like real natural ingredients.
There are a lot of body washes out there. They make you smell like a teenager.
Um, why don't know what a teenager smells like.
And I think that's a good thing that keeps me off. A lot of watch lists, lists,
lists. Uh,
this mint and Cedar Wood bodywash is amazing and makes you smell incredible.
Evidentaly that is all one flavor. Somebody sent it to me. Uh,
you got to give it a try. Once you're in the club,
you'll see the products work amazing the services world-class.
There's no longterm commitments, no hidden fees,
and you can cancel whenever you want. And Best of all,
they're giving away a one month trial of any of their raises for dollar with
free shipping. And after that, it's just a few bucks.
Get your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com slash burger that's dollar shave
club.com/bar okay. Oh, Jesus. Oh Jesus. If you don't like Christmas shopping,
okay, if you're wondering why you have to buy another full grown fucking adult,
Goddamn, you know, you know, whatever. A fire engine or some shit,
if he just like to get it done is the thing you do right here.
Just get him some Sherry's berries, man. Or you get it a woman,
they gonna appreciate it. Maybe they'll even fuck you.
Who knows what they are thinking. I don't pretend to know. All right,
you get it for a guy. It's fucking hilarious.
Getting your guy friend chocolate covered strawberries. I challenge you.
Give for funniest fucking, it's funny. There you go, sweetie.
I love you. Uh, take this to Sherry's berries. Take the stress out of shopping.
Chew Sherry's berries instead.
Tis the season of fucking sharing.
Follow La la La la, la, la La.
This is the copy known as it just said. Tis the season of sharing and shopping.
No matter who you're shopping for.
Sherry's berries is the one stop shop for everyone on your list.
Can you believe I blew out my voice defending the Los Angeles Rams while playing
the Atlanta Falcons? When the fuck do I give a fuck about the NFC west?
No matter who you're shopping for,
Sherry's berries is the one stop shop for everyone on your list.
You don't have to battle the crowds to get the perfect gift shop with
convenience right from your home.
[inaudible]
tell a personal story. Go Fuck Yourself. It's chocolate one strawberries.
It's America. Eat it and enjoy it. Uh,
the scripture words for berries, decadent, fresh, juicy.
Let's just get to the shit here. Uh, with Christmas right around the corner,
there's only one way to get these amazing 1999 Sherry's berries deal, uh,
and help support our show. Just visit, uh,
berries.com B e r r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone in the top right hand corner and type in Burr.
Sherry's berries has something for everyone and every taste. Go to berries.com.
Click on the microphone. Type in birth. Order them today. All right.
What do we got left? Uh, we got three left,
so let's get over the hump here and we'll do this real quick. A tipsy elves.
Everybody. You know what?
I saw some middle aged white lady with the Wu Tang clan Christmas sweater.
I think that sets the bar.
It was the classic Christmas sweater pattern with the Wu Tang w on the front and
it was black and yellow, right?
Didn't they used to say killer bees or some shit like that? I don't know.
All right. Tipsy elves.
Everyone needs an ugly Christmas sweater this time of year.
If you want bragging rights for the most. Talked about sweater,
your Christmas party. Listen Up. Talk, uh,
talk about your tipsy of sweater and other products you saw in their website.
Well, you know what? I did look at him. You know what? You know what?
I'm going to do that this week. I'll do that this week. What the fuck?
Here we go. Tipsy elves. I can talk about your fucking sweaters.
Tipsy elves. Here we go. What do they got?
Oh, Jesus Christ. Those things are fucking hideous.
They got Jesus Christ like as a baby,
but he still has the beard and one of those things. What are those things?
You know, you carry a baby and around Front Satchel,
you know they got Santa Claus on a Unicorn. Yeah, this is ugly as shit.
Men's Christmas suits.
I guess that's if you want to get on TV at a sporting event,
um, oh my God, dude, I can't even fucking read.
What does it say? Belt digger.
I thought it said the n word. That's what I first thought it's on.
And then I thought I'd said Gold digger. And you know what?
Why don't I get off this site? Uh, you miss,
you drink a birthday boy and it's got Jesus Christ.
Alright? You know what these people went.
They got the most fucked up looking shit I've ever seen. Um,
everyone needs an whatever. Tipsy elves has hundreds of Christmas sweaty.
I just talked about this shit. You get what they are. You know what they are?
How do you get them right?
Now my listeners get 20% off tipsy elves at [inaudible] dot com tipsy,
spelled t I p. S. Y. You might've said it,
he might have been called it, but did you ever have to spell it?
Tipsy tip s y l s.com on anything they order in the site.
Go to [inaudible] dot com enter my code Burr at checkout and get 20% off your a
site wide discount. Everything you gets 20% off,
that's tipsy elves.com and your code bird. You know,
you've got a bunch of Christmas parties coming up and if you wear that sweater
and you get fucked up, I mean it makes it even funnier.
No one's going to get upset, right? Anyways,
I've been hanging with my wife, you know, barely doing any standup,
just sitting there waiting for the kid to come and a poor thing.
She's all really uncomfortable. She's at the point, she's been such a trooper.
She's at the point now, she's just like this, get this kid out of me. Right?
And, uh, last night was the first time I saw kick through this fucking kick.
Like, uh, I do these exercises, you know,
I have to help me do these exercises that she can try to stay Limba and I just
saw like, it was literally like, it was like a foot just fucking kicked aside.
It was just like, it's insane. It's insane that there's a God damn kid in there.
It's the most amazing fucking thing. And also like, yeah, just say to your wife,
like, I, there's no way for them to convey it to you. It's like,
what is it like to have a person in you
living inside of you? It's like, can you watch alien now and just be like,
I get it. I totally fucking get it. Um,
so anyways, uh, I hung out with her one night,
right? And we watch Rudolph the red nose reindeer.
Then we watched a frosty the snowman as much as I could watch,
you know, I don't get into frosty the snowman. It's too fucking it.
That one just gives me anxiety.
You watch Rudolph the red nose reindeer and it's slightly about racism and
acceptance, you know what I mean?
His own dad is ashamed of them and then he tells him to fuck off.
And then there's all the misfit toys. There's something going on there.
There's like this about racism and special needs kids. I don't really,
there's just so many fucking other things going on that it's really fucking sad.
And you watch it and it's 50 years old and you realize so much as it changed.
And then if you go right into frosty the fucking snowman,
and then here's this adult that's going to get on a fucking Choo Choo train with
some little girl, she doesn't tell her parents she's fucking leave leaving.
And then there's the fucking stress that it's gonna melt. I was just like,
you know what? You got to shut that. I can't handle this. Right.
I can't fucking handle this. This given me too much anxiety. Right. And, uh,
so then we switched over and we watched a little bit of Mary Poppins,
which I haven't seen in a long time, but I get all of those movies confused.
You know, the supercalifragilisticexpialidocious that,
that one Chitty Chitty Bang Bang. It's always some fucking old guy,
rich guy whose wife died and now the new hot piece of ass comes in and she shows
them how to fucking loosen up. You know what I mean?
That role has now been taken over by African-Americans, right?
They come in and they teach the uptight white dude how to fucking, I dunno,
do the electric slide. I never watched those fucking movies, you know?
But back in the day, it was a, it was a new fucking like chicken,
the guy's life. But this one, he was like married, but it was Dick Van Dyke.
You know, I sing in gym gym or a chimp, Chaminade, chimp,
chem-e Cho ro. They'll lifer of, of a fucking sweeper.
That's what I want to do, right? They, they're all fucking happy as hell.
You know, completely romancing blue collar work.
Like rich people are all fucking miserable.
And these people who are just going to die at 39 fucking miner's lung or somehow
dancing around up on the roofs, you know, covered in fucking [inaudible].
And I got through as much as that as I could get through. And uh, you know,
I bought a Christmas tree and I did all the dishes.
I watched all of that shit and like, you know what,
the next morning I was going to the rams game.
So everything that I did in the last 24 hours is just completely wiped up.
It's fucking unbelievable. But that's how it works, man.
That's how it fucking works. Um, so anyways, um, oh,
here's something that I did not mention as, uh,
this is something you have to do as a man,
especially if you have a wife and a family.
You got to get life insurance and I'm doing it this fucking week. I just,
you know, lost another friend who didn't fucking have it. And uh, you just,
you have to fucking do it guys.
We don't like dealing with our fucking mortality.
I know you've watched enough for the first 48 that you literally given your wife
a motivation to fucking take you out. You know what I mean? Um,
but she gotta do it. You gotta fucking do it. So I'm doing that this week.
It's been a brutal fucking week. Uh, this week I learned about loss,
you know, like I didn't already have enough fucking examples.
I got the old fucking right there, Fred this week. Um, anyways,
plowing ahead. Um, how about the fucking giants?
I'm fucking amazing at the New York football giants every fucking year.
I've been saying it all year.
Eli Manning is bored in September and October and then, oh wait,
we gotta fucking win some games here. He just,
the guy just comes to fucking life. They beat the fucking cowboys again.
They got this amazing fucking defense. This is,
this is what I'm so jealous of as a patriots fan.
I don't fucking get how I was first for going. Like,
why do we always have to get rid of our guys that are getting becoming stars
this year? Chandler Jones, we got rid of and a, what's his face?
We sent over to the fucking browns, you know,
always for the same shit of fucking second round draft pick. You know,
we got rid of channel Jones and uh, when,
what's the other fucking guy's name from fucking Florida University? Whatever.
I, I'm s the guys, I'm so fucking busy with my wife right now.
I don't even know who the fuck's who right now, but it's just like,
what I hate about the fucking patriots speaking of balance is we have all our
money on the offensive side of the ball.
All our stars are on the offensive fucking side and we're forever getting rid of
these fucking cornerbacks.
Why won't we pay a fucking quarterback all the way back to Thailand,
lawyer Malloy. We just constantly get rid of those fucking guys.
You know, you watch, we're going to,
we'll get rid of that fucking kid who pygmy that pick in the fucking super bowl
in Seattle, but fucking get rid of him when he wants a contract. I don't,
I don't fucking get it. Bronx paid. Brady's paid.
I mad at magic. Edelman's going to get paid if he's not paid already.
And then nobody on the other side of the fucking ball it seems like whenever
they, whenever they do,
whenever they fuck defense wins fucking championships and we fucking are forever
doing this. You watch tonight,
how many points is Tom Brady going to have to put up on the fucking scoreboard
to beat the ravens who always have a good defense? I fucking love the ravens.
I love the giants. I love the Steelers. I love those fucking teams that just,
they always have a great fucking defense.
What kills me about the giants is they got this fucking killer defense and they
still have Eli. They got fucking, what's his face there? Who you know,
Jesus Christ. What a fucking diva. He is evil. He's not on the field.
He's got to be like, you know, trying to get the crowd going.
Like they're not into the game. I fucking hate that shit. You know del Becca,
it's like we get it. We get it. You're a superstar.
It's not enough that you'd had a one headed 90 yard fucking catch.
Now you gotta be sitting there fucking up on the Goddamn say at stands doing the
y YMCA dance with the fucking crowd.
Literally like the defense is out there shutting down the Dallas cowboys and the
fucking cameras on you.
Cause you fucking do with Christmas carols with the fucking front section.
That drives me up the wall. Right? They got him, they got,
they still have enough money for that fucking do crews. It's, it's,
it's amazing.
But somehow bill Belicheck trades these fucking guys and gets like three or four
second round draft picks, then eventually mature into these stars.
And then we went and title and then it's like,
then they want their money and then we fucking get rid of them again.
So believe in it. Not as much as the Patriots are,
you know,
looked upon as a number one or number two seed maybe behind the Raiders.
I Dunno, I haven't watched the last couple of weeks. I know the Broncos lost,
um, I don't know how it fucking works,
but you got to think that we're one of the favorites,
right to go to yet another fucking super bowl. But, um,
this is actually a rebuilding year for us. That's how great bill Belicheck is.
But, um, I think we're, the Patriots lose tonight unless we split,
we got to put up like, I would say like 38 points,
cause Joe Flacco is no fucking slouch. Um,
I dunno, I just don't have any fucking faith in it.
And I don't think that the Patriots' defense stinks.
I just think every fucking year they're good guys, you know, one or two guys,
it seems good seal fucking evil. Um,
you know what the Patriots are really good at.
We're really good at finding that fucking white dude who for no fucking reason
is fucking really fast. The Westwell course, right?
The elements, the am and Dole is, we, that's what the fuck we are good at. And,
um,
the giants are great at finding fucking those guys that are built like our, our,
as fast as a linebacker, but for some, some, somehow our,
the size of a defensive end, they get all of those fucking guys,
they spot them a mile away. Somehow we can't find them, you know?
And I think the Ravens in the, uh, Steelers, they, they,
they're really good at just getting those hall of fame fucking defensive backs
in linebackers. Ed reads, Ray Lewis, fucking Steelers,
you can name like 50 Goddamn fucking people right from the fucking steel curtain
all the way up to a Paula Malo. They just stayed that enough. They just,
they're just fucking good at it. So, um, having said that,
I've been also watching my Bruins. Um,
I'm still trying to see where, where we're working towards.
When we sent the entire Stanley Cup winning team gave, you know,
over the course of two and a half seasons sent every significant player from
those teams out the door except for Ciara and uh,
Marshawn and Burgi. I don't know.
I don't see where a year and a half end of this shit. I don't,
we're still a fucking eighth seed.
This is right where we were last year and I swear to God,
if they make our coach take the fall for this, all right, we better keep him.
And at the end we feel if we think that this doesn't work out all right.
You definitely keep a closed Julian. You definitely keep Cam Neely,
but a Michael Connell's gotta fucking go. Cause he's the guy on me.
As far as I know. He's the guy that fucking did all of this. I don't know.
But you know what? The fucking Bruins never want to pay anybody
and fucking believable do Pasternak has 18 fucking goals, right?
I watched some of the Toronto game yesterday. I know we lost three to one.
I don't know who scored. I missed that part. And uh, he's got 18 fucking goes.
He imagine if Sagan was there, we would have, we been had two fucking lines.
At least we admit we fucked up when we got rid of say can but whatever.
But you know something the Celtics are looking go to Al Horford is the fucking
real deal and I think he's a fucking leader. I think he's got,
he's like a fucking superstar and he's not a fucking headcase.
I'm loving that guy. You know, we've got Isaiah Thomas, we got a point guard,
we got a guy down low who actually can fucking pass the ball.
Please brought the ball up the court as much as everybody's freaking out about
what are the Greek freak there? The bucks is a bunch of guys.
Six foot 11 could do that. I'm a fucking Lebron James.
He's been doing everything that that guy does just because he doesn't play the
point guard position. Everybody's fucking freaking out. But that guy is amazing.
All right. But uh, I dunno,
I'm loving what Danny h is doing and uh, I think that we're one guy away.
I don't know much about who,
whoever that middle guy is between your number one and your number five to power
forward. I don't know what the fuck we need a two with three.
I Dunno what the fuck it is. But uh, if we could just have another guy bench,
we play great fucking defense. I don't know.
I benches a little suspect of right.
Kelly Olynyk comes in and that other fucking guy who can't, I swear to God, I,
I think I could literally beat this guy taken foul shots. He's one of them.
He's the one like was it smart? The guy with the fucking blonde hair? Um,
anyway, so let's, uh,
let's get to some of the questions here for this fucking week here.
I to wrap this up too, cause the people putting the at the punch lists,
guys are coming back to put the finishing touches on the kitchen. Oh by the way,
you know, this is free advertising
and a Campfire Cook trop top grill. You gotta get one dude.
I got one in my backyard. My wife was fight me on that thing. I finally,
I shut her the F up.
I went out and I made she steak and cheese is one of her favorite fucking
sandwiches. I went out there, I went on the Internet,
I looked for a simple fucking recipe.
All I did to season the meat was a little wishy shire sauce and some salt.
That was it, right? I had white American cheese.
My wife isn't into peppers and onions. I was like, fine.
I saute the little bit of mushrooms.
I these fresh French rolls to fucking game over,
game over. She ate that thing. She didn't have time to say how great it was.
She just fucking Wolf that thing down. And I was really sitting there like,
you know, I need the approval. I'm like, was it good? You're Joyce. She's like,
how about the fact that I ate it in a minute and I couldn't even talk because my
mouth was full. So that's how good it was as fucking site. I haven't even done,
I haven't even, you can do Rubens on that fucking thing.
You can make the whole grand samp slam breakfast, Hash Browns, pancakes, Bacon,
the whole fucking get the bacon going. Slide the bacon over.
You put the Hash browns in that fucking grease. Go Fuck Yourself.
Jason Law had already gave it the nickname because I'm bringing it to the Rome
Rosebowl. He calls it the game changer and uh,
he's going to be making Reuben's that day. Like he's literally,
Jay law had his is a fucking ridiculous Cooke.
He's unbelievable, right? He's so excited about that thing.
He like dropped his voice like three octaves.
I sent him a picture, he was saying, I go, dude,
you guys see what I got for the tail Kay tailgate this year. He goes,
I really do what you get. What'd you get? And I show it to him.
He was just like, dude, dude,
you got to cook top dude. That's fucking limitless. Hey,
you can do Brata, you can do Ruben, she can do breakfast or anything.
Just fucking rattle and all. I just started laughing. He goes, that thing,
that thing is a game changer. It's literally a fucking game changer. Um,
he was ah, I can't even tell you the ideas that he,
cause he told me I should put out my own one.
He had all these fucking great ideas, but I don't want anybody to steal it.
I probably won't put it out anyways, but, um, so, um,
okay.
Ah, steak and cheese isn't, oh, on the, forget about on the Diet, by the way.
I've done a cardio everyday this month. All right. 11 days in,
I got day 12 here. I'm telling you,
go through the holidays just to a fucking half hour cardio every fucking day.
All right. And you pick your spots. We eat like a fucking more on eight,
like a more on yesterday, and then today you get right back on it, you know? Um,
and that way you start the year, you know, you're not a fat fuck.
You don't get that extra 10 to 15.
You don't want to deal with that shit or you know, or whatever.
Don't listen to me all listening. Okay, here we go.
Let's get to the emails for this week. Um, alright mom.
Worried about me traveling dear Billy scrotum head.
I didn't know what that's just fucking mean for me and say my girlfriend and I
have been dating for five years now and finally decided to travel abroad
together. You'd taken your broad abroad. Um,
she is a seasoned traveler, but I have yet to have traveled internationally.
Well, that's great. She knows what she's doing. Just follow her lead. Uh,
we recently person purchased tickets to Greece to pop my cherry, uh,
sell slash celebrate her birthday. Um,
well that's great. Uh,
I just told my mom about the trip and a few days later received a text from her
very worried about traveling to Greece slash out of the country.
I'm 27 years old, uh,
mom and scared of me getting a, you left out some words here, buddy.
My mom is scared of me getting killed due to the country's current state and
terrorists. My mom took a few days research, all the negative things,
unemployment, bankruptcy, et Cetera,
about Greece to try to dissuade me from going, well,
if she looked up the fucking, is it Santa Maria Santa Rally with the fucking,
that's Frank Senegalese, the comedian.
What's that fucking beautiful place you can stay? It's all, every,
all the buildings are white. It's right on the Mediterranean Sea.
If she looked that up, she'd be fine. Listen,
if you live in America and you just sit in your, in your,
if you're going to listen to the international news,
they're not going to talk to you about great shit.
You gotta watch the travel channel. If they're going to show the news,
all you're going to hear is bad shit.
That's like everybody in everybody in England thinks everybody like over here
weighs 400 pounds and owns 15 guns and you walk down the street,
have with them on your hip. You know what I mean?
I see just as many fat fucks in, in fucking Great Britain. Maybe not as much,
but there's a lot of fish and chip eating fucking rotten teeth,
dirty, dirty white people out there. Um, but that's all I,
that's all you're going to know. Tell her to put on the travel channel.
Send her a couple of fucking links. All right. Anyways, he goes,
I understand that she's worried about her son,
but I'm also aware that she lives in a shell and she has never traveled abroad.
Um, after hearing on the podcast that you have been to Greece recently. No,
I haven't. I want to go there.
I went to Italy recently by a question for you is,
do you think an average Joe first time, parentheses,
nervous travel like myself will feel safe? Any words to put me at ease?
I would love to hear what you have to say.
Good or bad as this will help in my decision to,
the greatest fucking thing is you're going, um,
with your girlfriend and she's a seasoned traveler.
She'll know what the fuck to do. So just follow her lead.
But I would encourage you to step out of your shell, learn a couple of phrases.
The locals love when you make an attempt to speak their language, even in Paris,
as much as they get shit,
if you're really fucking trying and you're showing respect for their culture and
you're on your best behavior. That's another thing too. When you travel abroad,
you're on your best behavior. Unlike all these fucking Europeans.
So many of them that come over here and they literally start trashing America to
you in the United States of America. It's like Jesus Christ.
What the fuck is wrong with you? You know what I mean?
Like as much as I was just teasing, when I go over there,
I'm on my best fucking behavior. All right? I go on stage,
I'll tease him a little bit, but in general,
I talk about what a great fucking time I'm having there.
You can easily pick apart any fucking place that you go to. Um,
so anyways, I would learn a couple of phrases. Um, too, you're going to eat,
you're going to have food over there like you've never had here before.
You're going to see things you've never had.
You have to swim in the Mediterranean Sea. It is fucking life changing.
And Dude, I'm telling you right now,
if you have any sort of stress in your life,
if you stay along the Mediterranean from Spain all the way over to like,
you can't fucking Miss, you know,
just all I would say is just watch out for pickpockets.
Okay. Those gypsies are,
are the fucking bill Belichick and Tom Brady's of pickpocketing. I mean they,
it is a fucking art form. They're so good at it. You almost won't be mad. Like,
how the fuck did they do that? All right.
So that's the biggest thing that I would worry about.
And especially watch your wife with their big stupid fucking purses and they're
all excited and they're fucking looking around. This is what you do. All right?
You make a copy of the passport. Okay.
Copy you fucking passport and you fucking keep you, you know,
have it in the safe at the fucking hotel. All right? Keep it at the hotel.
I take my chances with some cleaning lady taking your passport.
She ain't going to fucking do that. Right. You have a copy of that. All right.
Um,
I would definitely wear some sort of fucking like pants that have zippers on
them that you can zip that shit shut and when a bunch of people start coming up
to you crowding you, be it on the subway or anything like that,
you put your hand on your fucking wallet, you have it right there.
I wouldn't had, don't have any fucking thing of value whatsoever.
And I'm telling you right now,
this is probably making you fucking nervous or whatever. This is just,
this is just, you know, misdemeanor stealing shit,
but we'll make your life fucking miserable because you're going to have your
credit cards and all that type of shit and your money and all of that.
It's just, you know,
pickpockets is the only fucking thing that I ran into when I was over there.
That's the only thing you have to worry about and just really,
really be super fucking hyper fucking aware when you're walking up to um,
whatever the fuck tourist teeth and what are they going over there?
They have the ruins, all of that shit. You know, you're going to go any,
any of that type of stuff. Like in Paris, if you go up to the Eiffel Tower,
you have your hands on your shit. And when people come walking up to you,
I'm speaking in English. Just literally just fucking go.
No Loblaw no are blown. Just fucking, and if they keep coming at you, just say,
get the fuck away from me. I'm telling you right now,
if you just tell him to get the fuck away from you,
any of those fucking broads coming up to you, they want to, you know,
you're at the Eiffel Tower, the Eiffel Tower.
What are you gonna you stand in line, you go on the Eiffel Tower,
get the fuck away from me.
They're coming up there to steal from you and watch out for their kids.
That's the only fucking thing. Cause they are fucking tremendous at it. Um,
that's all that. Anytime you walk out of there, and I would also,
the next advice I'd give you is I'm like,
just bring Carey on.
I didn't even say that to your wife to just bring your girlfriend. Just bring,
carry on.
You're going to wear the same fucking tee shirt and shorts basically every
goddamn day. No one's going to give a fuck. You're on vacation,
flip flops and all of that type of shit. Okay. All I can say is just like,
you know, under pack and if you want to buy, um,
if you want to buy like some touristy shit, you know, I love, I love magnets.
I love those patches,
those flags that you're going to sew onto a coat or some shit. You know,
you have the memories, you have the pictures, you would,
what are you gonna you don't need to go out and buy some wooden shoes and a big
beer Stein. If you want to buy some shit like that, ship it back. Do that.
Just go there and have a good time.
Watch your fucking valuables when you're around.
Fucking if you're on the subway and if you're near anything touristy other than
that, have a great fucking time. Chill out.
Eat the best fucking food you ever gonna fucking have and swim in the
Mediterranean Sea and you'll have those memories for your whole fucking life.
It's the greatest fucking thing and I feel bad for your mom that she's never
traveled outside of the country because it's a great thing. All right. Clingy,
girlfriend, clingy girlfriend, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
Hey Bill, as you may have read from the title of this email,
I am dealing with a clingy girlfriend.
We've been dating for three months now and pretty much have only known each
other,
but we've been dating for three months now and pretty much I've only known each
other for three months now, so it's a pretty new relationship. Okay,
so I get it. You didn't work with her gradually.
Work up the balls you saw and you said, bitch, you come with me.
And she was like, oh my God, he's so direct. Anyways,
as I've gotten deeper in the relationship,
I've started to notice more and more red flags. I'll tell you this right now.
If you start noticing more and more red flags, three months in, I'm are.
I already have my finger on the fucking eject button personally this far into
your email. Okay. For, for example, a,
she gets mad and starts crying.
If I want to go to the gym by myself and not bring her up, fuck this, uh,
over, over, over, over,
okay.
Fucking over. Or if I don't reply to her texts within five minutes,
she calls me and asks me why I haven't answered. She's even already said,
I love you to me. And actually set it back when we were having sex,
accidentally said, I love you.
Only a guy can say that and now she says it back to me all the time and I
haven't and I have to say it back because I don't want to break her heart and
tell her that I don't feel the same way. Well, you already have.
You already have. All right, just give her a three month broken heart.
Get out to get out. I've even tried to break up with her like a week ago.
Get Out, get out.
And she started to have a breakdown saying how much she needed me and how she
can't live with that. Get Out,
get out, get out of here. So I told her, yeah,
we could just stay together because I felt that. All right dude,
you've basically already broken up with her. [inaudible] she goes,
she also just randomly flat out said that she can see us together forever.
I don't know why I'm noticing all these things now,
but I'm only 19 years of age. Well there you go dude. To be honest,
I still [inaudible] sorry.
The fuck is going off my throat here. Screen too much to say. And to be honest,
I still want to live the bachelor lifestyle and not be in a relationship with,
you know, all the answers to your question.
Try all the different fish in the sea. Sorry if I sound Douchey,
but I just really need help here, but I don't know what to do. Thanks bill.
And come back to, I'm not going to say the name of the state.
This chick's such a psycho. Um, yeah dude. Uh, this is what I would do.
Um,
and I'm taking this from Al Madrigal,
the Great Al Madrigal who no one knows how to en shit like him.
Um, if you listen to any of our live ATC podcast,
he worked in his family business and at your age 19 he was already,
he was the hatchet man. He fired adults and he told me one time,
the best way to get out of a relationship, okay,
if this is for everybody to do this,
you have a woman in your life and you have to break up with there are going to
drag you through the shit. Okay?
If you want to expedite the deep planning process,
um,
if she has anything over your apartment, get it all together, put it in a box.
Call her, say we need to talk. You show up with the box. You handed the box.
You tell her it's fucking over,
okay.
Right? You let her cry. You fucking leave. Now,
if she has keys to your place,
you don't even need to ask for him back. You already have changed the locks.
If she offers to give you the keys back, you take them,
but you never offer the information that you have changed. The fucking locks.
It's out. It's over. It's done. Dude. Rip This bandaid off.
That's your fucking Christmas gift and anybody out there right now,
male or female, if you're in a relationship, you don't want to be in. Fuck it.
Do it. Do It fucking tonight. Get you boxed together.
Change your fucking logs and the shit. Your Christmas gift.
Don't go to another fucking family event.
Someone else's family that you don't want to fucking be with.
You owe it to yourself. Get the fuck out of it. Alright, messy girlfriend. Uh,
hey Billy. Oh,
I live with my girlfriend for the past few years and I've tried and failed
repeatedly, repeatedly to get her to tidy up after herself.
She lives like a borderline slub with piles of her shit everywhere,
on most available surfaces.
Instead of putting stuff away after herself should just leave it out for days.
Most days I'll come back from work and the bed will be piled high with clothes
and the dump contents of handbags, et cetera.
In the in the evening, very underrated Zepplin song. By the way,
this will be off. This will often, uh,
just get moved to the Sofa and then in the morning moved back to the bed.
Every cover in drawer is piled full of shit.
I have a couple of small spaces for my belongings.
Everywhere else is full of clothes she hasn't worn from months, parentheses,
question mark years dozens of handbags purchase. She doesn't person,
she doesn't use bits of paper cards. She keeps,
she's keeping for who knows what dozens of beauty products she get the picture.
I do try to keep things tidy at best I can for my own sanity,
but it'd be nice to have not,
not to have to nag her every so often to just tidy up after s after self.
I keep I,
if I kept pissing on the toilet seat and she kept telling me how annoying it
was, I think she'd be right in thinking what the,
what the Hell is wrong with this dude?
Surely tidying up after yourself is about respect for the other person or people
you live with. I know the whole accept me for who I am,
bullshit and all and all of that. But come on, I was wondering what your,
you are the, the lovely Nias um, Leno's thoughts on this are,
um, um, well I'll tell you this too. Uh,
that's not gonna get any better. And she sounded,
you got a small time hoarder on your lot, on your hands here.
Forget about if you get married and have kids. Um,
so you gotta you gotta ask yourself right now,
are you going to marry this person if you're not,
pack up your own box and get the fuck out of there and already have an apartment
ready to go. By the way, you pack up your box,
you bring this shit over to the fucking apartment while she's at work.
Then you call her, you say, listen, we need to talk.
And then you get the fuck outta there. You say,
I'm going for a drive.
You drive over to new apartment and then you call her up from a pay phone and
you say, by the way, when I said I was going for a drive,
what I really should've said was, I just moved out. Uh, good luck to you. And,
uh, you know, let's, let's try and win in Chicago. You hang up,
you go the Robert Kennedy, they're right. It's fucking over. Um,
I can tell you right now, dude, I couldn't tolerate that.
I couldn't tolerate living with the fucking slob. There's no,
I fucking hated that when I lived, when I had guy roommates, I was,
I never understood that.
Like how guys thought it was funny to have like fucking pizza boxes and all this
like live in like a fucking animal. It's like, guys, we live here.
It's fucking gross. Um,
so you have to decide if you love this person enough to accept this part of them
or you have to, or maybe you throw down an ultimatum. Like,
if there's no fucking way I'm living my life like this,
this is completely unacceptable.
You have way too much shit you need to throw out. At least 70% of your shit.
Okay. And if she gives you a rough time and just say, listen, you eat,
eat it. That shit is going out the door or I am.
Are you saying that you're choosing that over me? Yes.
Yes. Cause I'm telling you right now, I am not going to be happy.
Are you telling me that you love your fucking bags more than you love me?
Just turn that stupid psych psychology shit right back on them.
Get it the fuck Outta here. It gets the fuck out.
Or I get the fuck out. And then you put on some Christmas music ever.
Holly Jolly Christmas, right? All right, here we go. Next one,
three stooges. I love Mr Burger. I was wondering who your favorite,
who's your favorite stooge? I know most people are curly fans,
but I've always been a shrimp fan. Any who have a good day. Um,
Shimp is unbelievably underrated.
The fact that he had to follow Curley and Curley was in bad health slash I think
might've died during his tenure. Um,
I love chimp. Uh, but curlier curly is the best.
But Larry Larry's under fucking rated too.
Larry's fucking hilarious. And Mo was the bully.
I could never get into demote cause I had an older brother that was just like
dad fucking asshole.
I used to love it every once in a while when moe would lose one of those little
slap battles. But, um, I loved all of them. And people always say, you know,
you're either a stooges fan or you like the Marx brothers.
I fucking hated the Marx brothers. I thought they were boring as shit.
I bet if I got a phone now that I'm older, maybe I'd enjoy it more. But, um,
I dunno. I just thought it was clever shit.
We're three stooges was just fucking, it was hilarious.
They were just beating the fuck out of each other. And the, I dunno,
it's clever as a joke is,
is there anything funnier than seeing somebody walking into a fucking window of
falling down a flight of stairs?
There's nothing funnier than watching somebody hurt themselves. Um,
I don't know. Maybe I'm just, maybe I'm just not smart enough. Uh,
you know what? I should look at the mark spreads it before he trash them.
I will tell you that one guy could fucking play the harp like nobody, Huh?
Alright. MVT they have atlas, very little advertising.
Then we'll wrap up the podcast. Um,
MVMT watches movement, watches, we get it. Holiday shopping can be tough,
but thanks to movement watches all that gift giving anxiety can disappear with
the press of a button.
These watches make the perfect purchase for just about anyone in your life.
A guy or girl. Remember these watches started only 95 bucks. All right.
Um, whatever. Where am I?
The holiday shopping season is here with moving watchers.
You can skip the crap that we just fucking sent this shit.
We want you to start at just $95 at a department store and you're looking at,
at a department. So it'd be looking at four to 500 bucks for these watches.
Over 500 thousands of these watches had been sold in over 160 countries.
Get 15% off today with free shipping.
Free returns by going to move into watches.com/spur this watch has a really
clean design. Um, seriously,
you be getting compliments everywhere you go when you put it on and it's only 95
bucks, uh, now is the time to step up your watch game. Go to movement,
watches.com/bar join the movement. And lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com whenever everybody with the holidays almost here,
you don't have time to go to the post office. You don't have time anyways,
especially during the holiday season.
The line's going to be out the fucking door.
It will be packed with everyone mailing holiday gifts and packages.
So do what I do.
Use stamps.com instead with stamps.com you can vote all the season,
all the hassles of the season man,
go into the post office during the bill's busy holidays, right?
Then the mailman, Ali bail man comes by, picks it up.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters and all of that shit.
I'm am I gifts? Fuck it. I'll try that this year. Trust me if I can do it.
You can't too. It's that easy right now. Um,
I can get you a better offer from stamps.com than what's on their homepage.
Sign up for stamps.com. Use My last name,
bird to get a four week trial plus a to $110 bonus offer that includes postage
and a digital scale scale. Go to stamps.com. Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburthatstamps.com enter bar. Um,
all right, that is the podcast, um, for this week.
Hope you guys enjoyed it. It's been a brutal week for me. Um, you know,
I'm very happy that we were able to find a new poem from my dog.
They've already sent us texts and pictures and she's totally fine and is,
you know, I'm glad that we didn't have to, you know, I was,
there was no fucking way any that that dog was not going to continue on living.
Uh, she's had an amazing life. She's lived like three different books. And,
um, me and my wife are happy to be where we do seven and a half years with her.
And, um, I love her to death. I'm going to miss her like hell,
but I had to do it because, you know,
the alternative was going to be something horrible and I did not want to have to
fucking live through that. Um, but I am devastated and um,
I would appreciate it if you don't send me any fucking insensitive tweets about
it cause I'm really on the ropes right here. All right. That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
And a La Checkin on you on Thursday.